hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel where today I'm doing another
sort of like quick news update thing
anyone who's been here for a while
you'll know that I have already spoken
about the effects that could be 19 it
all probably going to have on the games
industry we've already had some games
delayed like the outer world switch
point switch manufacturing the hardware
they had some delays ring fit has had
some delays and I suspect they're going
to be way way way more game delays
mostly because so many games are
manufactured in China even when you
don't realize like most nobody dog games
horizon zero dawn was a really big one I
imagine the lost of us two is probably
struggling with some of this but the
latest is from the Final Fantasy 7
remake which naturally it feels like
we've been waiting for already for a
really long time so almost two hours ago
the Final Fantasy 7 Twitter account
tweeted an important message for the
Final Fantasy 7 remake development team
from Brother
it says Wow back up big the Final
Fantasy 7 remake team have worked
extremely hard to make this game and
we're incredibly proud of what you are
about to play which for the record the
demo is really really good it's the same
one that I played at e3 but I still
highly recommend it our biggest
motivator during the development was
that so many of you willing us on and we
felt your enthusiasm and passion every
step of the way we had some hard
decisions to make during the final few
weeks before launch to disruption due to
distribution channels caused by the
spread of the kovat 19 virus these
unique circumstances have made it
difficult to align timing of our global
shipping this basically means that
manufacturers have either closed down or
at least had major delays when it comes
to actually shipping the game itself so
the game is done they just have trouble
shipping it our highest priority is that
all of you including those who live in
countries currently facing the biggest
disruption can play the game at launch
so we made the decision to ship the game
far than usual to Europe and Australia
I don't know that Europe and Australia
would be the countries facing the
biggest disruption but my guess is that
those are the channels that usually get
delayed and any Australians will know
how often we kind of get screwed over in
Australia when it comes to collector's
editions or physical delays I feel like
it
happens all the time and part of that is
because Australia is a remote island
that doesn't connect to anything that
everyone has to ship their stuff to it
continues to say as a result there is a
greater chance that some of you in these
regions will now get a copy of the game
prior to the worldwide release date of
April 10 meaning in this case Europe and
Australia are gonna get it earlier than
everyone else the physical copy of the
game oh we have an everyone else which
is kind of nuts but other western
regions including the americas copies
will be shipped this week and we feel
optimistic that most of you will receive
the game for launch day however due to
the challenging situation we cannot
provide delivery dates for each country
and each retailer the phrasing of this
is particularly interesting because what
has actually happened here is that well
what most companies would have done is
announced a delay the game is in theory
delayed because of shipping issues but
what Square Enix Pyaar has done here
which is the first time I've ever seen
anyone do this is try to do the opposite
so people don't get mad about a delay
and I'm really curious to see how this
goes over publicly obviously then uses
only gesture up they'll read of a some
of the Twitter reaction
my guess is people are gonna be mad
anyway but if this goes over okay then
maybe we will have less game delays this
year at least and instead they will have
games that release may be on time
digitally or get shipped earlier than
they normally would to some regions it
just it just means game release dates
are gonna be a mess probably but I would
way prefer that some people get a game
early and just hold off on spoilers and
wait politely then wait some way late a
date for the rest of the world to get it
because it's so hard to track that
during a literal global pandemic so
that's page one or two the second page
says we really want all of you looking
forward to Final Fantasy 7 remake to
play the game on April 10 and experience
everything we have been working on
together to everyone we would like to
ask one big favor if you got the game
early please think of others and don't
spoil it for them we know there are
potential spoilers that have been out
there for over two decades as the
original Final Fantasy 7 was released in
1997 but Final Fantasy 7 remake is a new
game that still has many surprises for
everyone all our fans and players
deserve to experience the game for
themselves and we are
for the support of our dedicated
community around the world to ensure
that on behalf the entire development
team and everyone around the world that
has worked on getting fun of Fantasy 7
remake to you all thank thanks again for
your support and most importantly please
stay safe this probably not gonna go so
well for them I can't imagine that
people will just not play the game until
April 10th which is kind of what the
pitch is here I don't really see that
happening if people in Australia or
Europe get it early which to be fair in
some cases Australia does get things
Olli I remember seeing Avengers way
earlier than it first came out in the US
the first one that was but sometimes
movies come out way earlier here and
people try not to cross that too much
but it's Tralee it does get games early
on occasion especially bethesda games
just because Australia and New Zealand
are the first in the world in terms of
the time sign so it does happen but
every single time it happens it does
mean Australians are streaming pretty
much immediately and my biggest concern
here especially being square is that
they will probably put some really harsh
restrictions on streamers to avoid
spoilers but I guess we'll see how that
goes but again this is this is a really
interesting approach to what would have
otherwise been a delay is that that they
are instead releasing the game early but
only for some people because if they had
have delayed it they probably couldn't
say when they were delaying it - which
is just going to be an impossible mess
and I feel like the people who are gonna
be upset about this probably people in
America or people who just kind of find
out one day that the game is late for
them but you do have to remember that
this is um not an easy call to make
because say someone in the US could get
like a certain store could get it in two
weeks another could get it in three it's
just such an unreliable way to release a
game and there is also no indication
here what they're doing digitally and I
think that that is the one thing that
people are gonna be really annoyed about
if I pull this over here the first tweet
reply that I can see is someone saying
it is an unfair decision for those who
buy the game in digital and clearly
reveals your opinion regarding those who
buy the games in digital perfect how
your company works I don't think that
this means that Square Enix hates
digital buyers that's an interesting
take translation we don't want more
people to find out that it is only
one-third of the original game before it
releases I don't know about that then it
looks like there are some positive
you guys hot sir in the right places the
sentiment is appreciated walk safely and
stay healthy thank you so much this is a
really complicated one this person said
I pre-ordered the game months ago but I
should go and collect my copy to the
store Game Stop in Italy all the stores
are closed I won't be able to play so
yeah I don't know what people who've
already pre-ordered the game are
supposed to do unless those ways that
they can cancel their physical
pre-orders online and just buy the game
digitally because most people yeah in
Italy they don't even allow to leave the
house the fifth week of quarantine at
home for us that's nuts I saying I can't
cancel if I can't go to this so I've
already cold I've already paid and given
a game they won't give me my money back
and they won't cancel the order that is
brutal and again this is gonna be just a
problem that I feel like we're gonna see
waves of in the games industry and this
is just when it comes to shipping Final
Fantasy 7 is already done it's so much
worse when it comes to the games that
can't actually get made because of
studios that have shut down all studios
that can't walk remotely was definitely
an issue in China when they had full
shutdowns for anyone that has a lot of
workers in Italy that's gonna be a
problem - I guess it kind of depends on
the regions and where they have the most
forced quarantine right now but yeah
this is this is definitely step one of
something that is going to be happening
a lot more and I do think that the
PlayStation 5 will get delayed not
positive about the the new Xbox because
they don't tend to manufacturers in
China quite as much but I feel like I'm
gonna have a big problem there why not
release the game only seems like it's
finished anyway that's not how the stock
market works I think that's that's like
a thing I talk about all the time that I
feel like people miss is yeah often a
game is done completely finished before
it ships but they're still working on
day one patches often until day one
which is a huge thing but also the date
that you release a game influences the
stock market significantly and you have
to communicate that stuff with
shareholders often in advance you can't
just kind of like hit a button and
release something like this guy said it
affects way more than just the people
who play the video games and it affects
the entire company's stocks and how they
manage their marketing budgets and how
they manage their quarterly earnings and
all of that stuff it's it's way way way
more complicated than just you're just
the publisher just release the digital
asset it
walk that way I don't know I feel like
most of these appositive will the
digital release be brought forward is an
interesting question but I just I think
pretty much everyone in this case should
just just for every game that that this
might happen to just has to cancel their
physical orders or maybe just do that
anyway
I'm very against pre-orders in any case
I feel like this year is probably a good
one to just cancel every pre-order you
have and go digital and I know that
sucks if you're a big physical collector
I've been one for a really long time I
had I don't know maybe like 300 or so
Xbox 360 games at one point it was kind
of absurd then I moved countries and I
was like you probably got rid of some of
that it's a bit of a waste but I feel
like just playing digital versions at
this point is a much smarter move
because they are gonna be shipping
problems with every single one of these
stores and people who aren't walking
GameStop's across the u.s. have all just
closed down yeah loads of people aren't
gonna be picked be picking their games
up or getting them shipped to them in
person it's just it's gonna be tough so
yeah I think that this is like the Final
Fantasy 7 remake team doing their best
to negate a really awkward situation
because the alternative is it just kind
of shows up for different people on
different dates and it's a free-for-all
on the internet and everyone can do what
they can so there instead trying to make
it so that people get it at least all
honorable for April 10 rather than just
sporadically at some point after that
date which is I don't know in my mind
like the friendliest approach to fans
they don't need to do that I feel like
this is again why don't all games do
this when they don't something this it
seems like a mostly positive response
and I don't know it's gonna be
interesting to see how the retailers
communicate this because obviously
anyone who's not seeing this tweet or
watch this YouTube video is not going to
know that this is a thing and it's going
to be very confusing for a lot of people
and it's just gonna happen over and over
and over again this year I'm pretty sure
start pre-ordering games ladies and
gentlemen just buy them when they come
out why would you buy something that
doesn't exist yet it doesn't make any
sense don't do it it's a bad idea
especially when it's like companies like
EA you're just giving them a guarantee
and then they can make whatever the hell
they want because they have the
guaranteed money if you don't give them
that money
they have to try harder to make a better
product so it'll sell better the more
they see that you've already bought the
thing the more control you give them
rather than giving yourself as a
consumer control I think it makes sense
I don't know I've been preaching this
for a long time
stop pre-ordering video games hi early
EB Games Australia released pessoa 5
Ryall le so I guess this is just the
same thing except that all the stores
will probably be closed maybe yeah maybe
they'll release it before the stores
closed I watched it EB Games in
Australia for a really long time maybe
like 5 years so I don't remember exactly
but we would pretty often get games way
before they came out but hey good luck
to everyone I hope nobody gets anything
spoiled again this is probably just the
first of a long list of these things
that that's going to happen and I'm
gonna leave a link in the description
below to a video I spoke about how I
think this is going to affect video game
development and I've also had a podcast
where I speak with a bunch of game devs
and an actual creators about how this
whole pandemic is affecting the games
industry as a whole so I will link to
those if you would like to watch them
but otherwise I guess we'll be seeing
Final Fantasy 7 remake a lot sooner than
we thought which is kind of exciting for
some of us alrighty everyone I'm gonna
I'll see you guys next time